hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make math less stressful and
more enjoyable so let's get right into
this video we're going to be talking
about matrix multiplication how to
multiply matrices so the first thing we
want to talk about when you talk about
multiplying matrices is is it even
possible to multiply them well the first
thing you want to do is you want to
analyze the dimensions of the matrix so
if the dimensions are 2 by 3 okay and
the other matrix is also let's just say
a 2 by 3 you won't be able to multiply
these matrices you want the number of
columns in the first matrix to be the
same as a number of rows in the second
Matrix so what I usually do is I write
the dimensions down first and I check to
see if those two middle dimensions match
if they match what you're going to end
up with are a matrix that has the outer
dimensions so it'll say that these
matched here you would end up with a 2x3
two rows three columns for your final
matrix after you multiply them so this
actually is not possible let's look at
another example say you had a three by
one okay times a one by three no problem
here you can see that these ones are
gonna match you're gonna end up with a
3x3 three rows three columns now in
normal math when you change the order
okay see if you multiply five times 6
that's the same as 6 times 5 with
matrices it's not always the same okay
matter of fact sometimes when you go to
change the order the matrix
multiplication might not even be
possible other times you'll get a matrix
this completely different dimensions so
you can see with this one if we change
the order we would get a 1 by 3 and then
a 3 by 1 the inner dimensions still
match but we're gonna end up with a 1 by
1 which is a completely different matrix
over here than a 3 by 3 even if you get
the same size matrix you're not
guaranteed to get the same elements in
that matrix so matrix multiplication
it's not commutative
with matrices okay like it is at normal
multiplication so let's look at some
examples let's look at this first one
let's analyze the dimensions we have two
rows and three columns so this is a 2 by
three matrix this one has one two three
rows and one column so we have a three
by one matrix you can see the inner
dimensions they match we're going to end
up with a 2 by 1 matrix so what I
normally do is I like to draw the matrix
so it has two rows and one column okay
so two rows one column and what I like
to do and I think this makes a little
bit easier for students is if you
actually work backwards you draw your
solution matrix here can your final
matrix and you say okay what position is
this in it's in the first row first
column that tells you what to do you're
going to take that first row right here
and you're gonna multiply it by the
first column now what I like to think of
doing is taking that row rotating at 90
degrees like this and it the ones that
match up the elements that match up
you're gonna multiply those together and
then add all those products so the other
way to think about is this is the first
element in the row this is the first
element in the column
you're gonna multiply those together
second element in a row second element
the column third element in the row
third element in the column both titles
together and then add so let's do this
we're going to do 2 times 1 which is 2
plus 1 times 0 which is 0 plus 3 times 5
which is 15 ok so if we simplify that
you can see we're gonna get 17
now the second element okay here is in
the second row first column right so
we're going to take the second row first
column again I'm just going to use that
technique that I was telling you I'm
just gonna think about rotating like
this 0 times 1 is 0 negative 1 times 0
is 0 and 4 times 5 is 20 so if we add
all those together we get 20 so our
final result is 1720 okay in the next
example let's look at this one these are
square matrices see how they're both
square shape they have the same number
of rows as columns and they're both 2x2
you're going to end up with a 2 by 2
okay you can still use that technique I
was showing you up there you've got a 2
by 2 and another 2 by 2 the inner
dimensions match
you're gonna end up with a matrix that
has these outer dimensions a 2x2 so 2
rows and 2 columns sometimes you don't
need every element in this matrix you're
maybe just interested in say like this
one so you don't have to go in order you
can just say well I want this one right
here so you say what position is that in
well it's in the second row second
column ok great let's take that second
row right here times the second column
we have negative 2 2 times 0 is 0 we're
going to add those together and we get
negative 2 ok so you can do them in a
random order say you want to do this one
here this is in the first row first
column no problem we take that first row
times the first column so that's 1 times
5 is 5 7 times 3 is 21 you add those
together that's 26 now you can see I'm
doing it in my head but if it was more
complicated I would write down each
product and then add them together
separately but if it's the numbers
aren't too large you can do it in your
head so let's look at this one here this
is in the first row second column first
row second column 1 times 1 is 1 7 times
2 is 14 14 plus 1 is 15 so I'm
multiplying multiplying multiplying then
I add all of them together last one
second row first column I take the
second row first column that's negative
10 and 0 which adds up to negative 10
okay last example I hope you're enjoying
this video if you are subscribe to the
channel and also check out at the end of
this video I'll have a link okay to a
playlist that has other types of
problems using matrices so we have a
whole kind of group of lessons here with
matrices that you can check out so let's
take a look at this last one now this
one has a dimensions of one row okay by
1 2 3 columns this one has 2 rows by one
column what do we notice not possible
right because it's a dimensional
mismatch ok so these ones you actually
cannot multiply together so again I hope
you're enjoying the video subscribe to
the channel check out the playlist on
matrices and I'll see you in the next
video talk to you soon